oh mein gott es ist besser als nichts
aus mit einer vorab info vielleicht am
besten wenn ihr irgendeine form von
männlichkeit besitzt dann klickt einfach
weg hallo liebe vieh schön dass du mich
mal besuchen kann willkommen in meinem
riesigen schlossgarten
jetzt ist mir doch schon wieder meine
kette gerissen
helfen sie wiederzufinden
allerdings wieder zu finden
das ist vor allem das allererste
lillifee spiel was würde spielen zwei
okay
red vein die second da ich sollte
hauptberuflich die perlen dings werden
und spaß wie dumm dass auch ist überall
wo dieses team einfach auf leuchte ist
einfach eine perle bestimmt auch am
seepferdchen hey du glaubst vergab zwar
nicht aber ich hab mir gerade für
runtergeladen
die antwort von dem kumpel nämlich dass
gerade geschickt habe ist wieso
ich weiß auch nicht vor auch um mode
wird zahlt ja ok freunde laut meiner
taktik da dieses dinge wieder leuchtet
wahrscheinlich ist die perle oder ok
hier leuchtet es auch noch dann ist hier
natürlich auch noch eine perle dadurch
dass auch noch dann ist der olympiade
und haben dennoch bonn erinnert kissel
ist nichts mehr sogar ich mein so ein
bisschen difficult wäre wenn es jetzt in
dem fischer wäre oder so aber ist es ja
nicht so da hinten locker auch noch her
klar sonst wird's doch nicht auf
leuchtender mir unten noch eine kleine
ding natürlich ist hier aber willst du
mich verarschen
was soll das das ist halt wahrscheinlich
echt die letzte perle oder tue ich mich
gerade da hinten nicht was ist das denn
für ein schwachsinn jetzt fehlt nur noch
eine die es ja hier weg gib mir doch
einfach die perle
es ist nicht wahr wie soll ich denn da
rankommen ich klicke hier drauf haben
nichts macht das ist nehmen die pille
so auf den ersten blick kann ich gar
keine perle sie hin
aber vielleicht hast du bessere
unterwasser augen schau dich mal um und
wenn du eine perle findest dann klick
sie einfach an
es müssen insgesamt 10 ich klicke es
doch an
aber das ist natürlich noch nicht genug
wir spielen natürlich noch ich ganz ganz
easy oh mein gott es ist besser als need
for speed mein gott dieser
geschwindigkeit
das ist echt alle die das
geschwindigkeitsgefühl ist so krank
gerade am besten wäre es wenn ich jetzt
noch eben schnell um die kurve driften
könnte
denn dann wird mir das spiel echt den
rest geben alter und spaß ein rennen auf
einem schmettern wie klein ist
eigentlich prinzessin lillifee wenn ich
einfach auf seinem schmetterling reiten
kann ich meine es ist einfach einfach
einfach einfach dass ich doch sogar was
habe ich denn jetzt getan
das war jetzt das komplette spiel
ihr freund das war's jetzt von diesem
video mehr hatte einfach ein user die
kommentare geschrieben spiel mal
prinzessin lillifee deswegen habe ich
getan ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt auch
wieso dieses spiel kostenlos wimmelt
damit mein handy wenn es euch gefallen
hat und eventuell mehr von solchen
behinderten spieler behindert das war
richtig gut
ich würde mich über eine bewertung
freuen und wer nämlich noch nicht
abonniert habt könnt ihr mich abonnieren
wenn ihr mehr von seinem schwarzen sehen
war jan bild ich sagen wir wir machen
jetzt mal eben schnell noch und ich mal
im ring du ein spiel gleich nochmal
spielen willst dann klicke hier mit
ehrlich gesagt nein ich will nicht
tschüss